[Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  will be worthwhile  you are  my mountain  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  when we first started out to tesla i  thought maybe we had optimistically a 10  chance of succeeding and uh here we are  today damn  [Music]  really entering a new phase of tesla's  future and scaling to extreme size as  you can see from this building it's not  small  this is the machine that builds the  machine the factory is the product  relative to production prototypes are  easy production is hard and this  building is the the most advanced car  factory that earth has ever seen  and now let us deliver our first tesla  cars made in texas  [Applause]  you